after an epic well-deserved entrance  today Okajima treated us to the first  look at his new game starring norman  reedus perhaps it's wishful thinking  after the cancelled silent Hills which  was also set to star norman reedus but  the upcoming ps4 exclusive from Kojima  Productions appears to have elements of  psychological horror as the game's  trailer showed the protagonists lying  naked on a beach next to a tiny baby who  then disappears we then see scores of  Dead Sea Life stretching out into the  ocean and then the game's title death  stranding stay tuned to gamespot for all  the latest on this one and everything  else that's turning heads at e3 this  week  you